دكتور ابراهيم مرحبا بك معنا هل هجوم
نتنياهو على عائلات الاسرى
ومظاهراتهم قد تجدي نفعا بالنسبه للجمهور
الغاضب وحجمه في الشارع
الاسرائيلي تحياتي لك والساده المشاهدين
يعني اعتقد ان نتنياهو يستمر بهذه السياسه
وبهذا الخطاب هو لم يغير بخطابه رغم ان
هذا الخطاب خفت وتيرته في الاسابيع
الماضيه حاول ان يظهر وكانه ليس العقبه
بوجه ايه الذهاب باتجاه صفقه ل ل تبادل
الاسرى ايه و قدمت العديد من البالونات
بالونات الاختبار فيما يتصل بهذا الموضوع
من قبل نتنياهو والحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن
في واقع الامر ما عبر عنه سموتريتش هو
الدقيق وهو الواضح الاولويه لدى نتنياهو
ولدى الائتلاف الحاكم هي الذهاب بالحرب
الى ابعد ما يمكن اي لسببين السبب الاول
متصل بان بقاء هذا الائتلاف وتماسكه وقوته
السياسيه مرتبطه باستمرار هذه الحرب
والسبب الثاني هو متصل بالبعد الاستراتيجي
ال النتيجه التي تلقاها والضربه التي
تلقاها الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد الس في
السابع من اكتوبر لم يتم ترميمها ول لم
يتم التعافي منها مشهد وصوره الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زالت كما هي ولم يقم بتحقيق
المنجزات التي يريدها على مستوى موقف
وصورته وقدرته وقوته كمنظومه رادعه وكمنه
حاميه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هنالك
اصرار لدى النخبه السياسيه بشكل عام
والائتلاف الحاكم بشكل خاص على هذا
الموضوع رغم ان هنالك بعض الاصوات التي
تبرز هنا وهناك تتحدث عن ضروره الذهاب الى
صفقه باي ثمن مثل ايزنو والمر وبالاضافه
الى هذا المستوى من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين والتباينات
بينيه
بينهم بالنسبه للشارع والجمهور
الاسرائيليه هل تلحظ تغير في التعاطي مع
توجهات الحربيه لمريدي الحرب من المسؤولين
والتوجهات
الاخرى من ايضا المسؤولين وايضا من اهالي
وجمهور الرهائن
يعني اسمحي لي هنا ان نقسم الجمهور او
الشارع الاسرائيلي الثلاثه اقسام القسم
الاول الذاهب باتجاه الحرب باي ثمن والذي
لا يقيم وزن للاسرى وهذا الجمهور اليميني
الذي يعبر عنه طياره الصهيونيه الدينيه
وجزء واسع من الائتلاف الجزء الاخر هو
الذي يريد ان يذهب الى هذه الحرب الى
النهايه ولكن يريد ان يحدث خلخله
وتحرك على مستوى تبادل الاسرى يريد الحصول
على الاسرى باثمان معقوله ولكن لا يريد
انهاء هذه الحرب لانه يدرك ان
الاثمان لذلك ثمن انهاء الحرب يعني هزيمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وبتال نقل المعركه الى
الداخل المستوى الثالث وهو ربما يكون
الاضي والمرتبط باهالي الاسرى مباشره
والذي يتحدث بالميدان عن الذهاب الى
التبادل باي ثمن واعتقد ان الثقل موزع بين
المستويين الاول والثاني وما زال الدائره
المحيطه باهالي الاسرى ليست واسعه بال
الشكل الذي يضغط ليؤثر على المشهد السياسي
حتى اللحظه نلاحظ ان رئيس المعارضه وراس
المعارضه ما زال بكابينه الحرب راس
المعارضه السابق جانتس ما زال بكبينه
الحرب حتى ايزن جووت الذي انتقد وطالب
بصفقه جريئه ايضا ما زال بمجلس الحرب
وبالتالي ما زالت هذه الحكومه متماسكه
مازال نتنياهو يمسك بقبضته على زمام
السياسه الاسرائيليه ويتحكم بخيوط اللعبه
كان هنالك
ايضا من لاحظ ايضا رده الفعل والراي العام
حول محكمه العدل الدوليه وما خرج عنها كان
هنالك في في كثير من المساحات ترحيب بهذا
القرار واعتباره ايضا انتصار جزئي رغم ان
هنالك اطراف تحدثت عن هذا اهتزاز لصوره
اسرائيل على المدى المتوسط والطويل وما هي
الديناميكيات دكتور ابراهيم التي من
الممكن ان تتحرك ل تفكك هذه الحكومه وتغير
توجهاتها مجلس الحرب تحديدا وليست الحكومه
وايضا تغير
ديناميكيات الجمهور
الاسرائيلي اذا توسع الشارع الضاغط باتجاه
الصفقه والمنتقد للحكومه بشكل اكبر
والمنتقد لمجلس الحرب ربما يدفع هذا يعني
جانتس وايزن جووت للانسحاب من هذا المجلس
تحديدا وهذا يؤثر على المشهد وث يؤثر على
العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اما على مستوى الائتلاف فاعتقد ان هذا
الائتلاف لا يمكن مواجهته حاليا من قبل
المعارضه بوضعها القائم بظل تماسكه ويمكن
ان يكون اي اختلال يحدث به من الداخل بشكل
اساسي بمعنى ايه انشقاقات ايه اهتزازات
على مستوى حزب الليكود يمكن ان تؤثر بهذا
المشهد وهذا على المستوى المنظور غير
ملموس لا يوجد مؤشرات لذلك كان هنالك
محاولات سابقه لكن هذه المحاولات يبدو ان
نتنيا
سيطر عليها وهو ما زال حتى اللحظه يدير
السياسه الاسرائيليه بقوه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ايضا لا تضغط بالشكل
المطلوب الذي يؤدي الى احداث اختلال سياسي
على المستوى الداخلي وشاهدنا خلال الايام
السابقه كل الدعم المعلن للموقف
الاسرائيلي قبيل نقاشات محكمه العدل وحتى
على مستوى الدعم العسكري المتصل باسراب
الطائرات الثلاث وبالتالي لا يوجد تغير
حتى بالموقف الامريكي بهذا الاتجاه
وبالتالي الشارع ربما يتحرك نعم ولكن
يتحرك داخل مجلس
الحرب نعم يعني اعتقد انه حتى اللحظه ما
زال جانس يحصد النقاط بمعنى ان هنالك فشل
سياسي على مستوى الشارع كيف ما يقاس
بالنسبه للراي العام يحمل لنتنياهو
بينما يصب كل هذا الفشل نقاط ايجابيه
لصالح جانتس وبالتالي لا يوجد ما يضغط
عليه للخروج من مجلس الحرب وخروجه من مجلس
الحرب سيحوله الى فاعل في الميدان وننظر
اليوم الى ان لبيد على سبيل المثال هو
موجود بالميدان لكن هو غير مؤثر وبالتالي
السؤال الذي اعتقد ان جانس ربما يسال
لنفسه في حال خرج من مجلس الحرب هل يمكن
ان يضيف نقاط الى نفسه اكثر من موقعه
الحالي الذي استطاع ان يقدم نفسه بخلاف او
من خلال دخوله لمجلس الحرب كقائد قومي اثر
المصلحه القوميه على المصلحه الحزبيه
وانضم الى خصمه اللدود من اجل اداره هذه
المعركه لا اعتقد
انه من الممكن بالنسبه له الخروج من مجلس
الحرب الا في حال استشعر ان هنالك خساره
من وجوده بهذا المجلس او استشعر بوجود
فرصه لاسقاط نتنياهو من خارج هذا المجلس